olá pessoal de 20 e hoje vou ensinar
como fazer uma troca de papel
eu fico fazer isso duas matracas no
canal do gabriel seja o canal de massa
invenções que é um canal que pessoal
está aqui deviso melhor vejam os últimos
vídeos e comparem com os outros de
alguns meses atrás bem esse trabalho tem
feito muito mesmo é estarmos lenta
qualidade de imagem e os projetos enfim
também é isso gente a fazer aqui uma
coisa assim de trocar subscrições de
mais um minutinho fazer um vídeo de
lucas e já fiz o vídeo deu e ela vai
fazer um vídeo meu que pronto ainda não
sei muito bem como é que vai ser
mas depois a gente vai ver passado
algumas semanas que está em provas é e
pronto hoje vou falar cinco com você não
sempre que dizer que testemunham
improviso está em um catálogo tem que me
deitar
aí pra voltar pra dizer que não somos o
com muito tempo livre e o estudo é
estudam em tempo integral seja o dia
todo e depois à noite faça os vídeos e
às vezes até quase uns quis dormir ok
então só para dizer que não arranja
desculpas aqui mas falta tempo a gente
tentar arranjar e fronteiras
o deixa dormir mais gente vai se
aguentar 10 a inclusão dos autos biz
placas do youtube é de placas por que eu
recebi do canal cleide pt que é o inglês
a etec do galatto também só quebrou um
pouco chegaremos de férias aí que eu
voltei de férias é e que não não tive a
oportunidade de vos mostrá las mas eu
vou mostrar daqui talvez uma semana ou
duas porque estou montar news tudo assim
entre aspas desembarque é que eu mandei
vir uma esponja daquelas acústicas que
vão guiar um estado dispõe de êxito à
espera que cheguem às outras
aí o pronto estou com a usina paredes já
dá pra ver uma pequena diferença no
áudio acho eu vou mostrar como é que o
quadro está a ficar está a ficar muito
bom mesmo
mantenha se em uma mesa com um tripé e
pronto assim mantém uma estratégia para
ajudar a gravar mais facilmente porque o
tempo é uma coisa cria no time
é em outra coisa vou fazer uma live que
vamos fazer uma live ele com master
invenções é quando o desvio é porque vai
ser no canal deu e eu vou confirmar pois
a data caiu e agora vou deixar aí uma
nota se neste vídeo pra vocês irem lá se
quiserem e pronto vocês quiserem lá
podem fazer perguntas sobre projetos
materiais alguma coisa que eu não tenha
visto nos tutoriais porque às vezes há
coisas que eu penso que faço e aí vocês
talvez não seja tão óbvio fora vocês
então será uma pergunta podem ir lá e
fazer vai ser minha primeira live eu vou
atrapalhar bastante contente com isso
não é porque eu sou assim não sou um
caso estranho né
é isso e já estou aqui e ver o tempo
estou quase a chegar ao fim sem 3027
quem estou a olhar para o que está a
acontecer no vídeo é então fronteiriça é
live isto fazer um vídeo para divulgar o
canal do mastro invenções passem por lá
inscrevam-se vou deixar também o link do
tutorial deu setorial que eu fiz estas
mostrar que a equipe ficou muito
explicadinho com de ser é isso vocês vão
perceber melhor vendo o vídeo de então e
só obrigado investido até a próxima
que tal e é